it was pretty hype today was one yeah it
sort of hit it was the same for us we
haven't seen the footage until last
night so we came out as found up as the
fans it was really really really
exciting we didn't screen the whole
thing this important yeah mentioned um I
tried none of us have seen the film and
we'll be seeing it at the same time as
you as you guys see it on April the 27th
because there's so much about the film
that's being kept under wraps being kept
secret so last night was about 20
minutes for you and and the first time I
seen it yeah you got sitting on your
only show the fans like 20 or 30 minutes
of the movie but even though you haven't
seen the complete movie having any of
you read the in full script know me
I like to read he has special special
powers I decide to sort of understand
what the context was strange as this
wonderful role and it you know I'm
trying to kind of hold the multiverse
together so kind of needed to know what
goes on in between those brackets yeah
anybody anyone called Tom or Chris
hasn't read it Holland is not allowed to
read I tried for about five minutes I
tried for about five minutes to get the
script and just gave up so quickly I'm
feeling that I was never gonna win tom
hollie time bad at keeping a secret Tom
H is that true and that producers went
to extreme lengths to keep you from
knowing what actually happens in the
film I'm very stressed right now because
this is live so I'm really trying
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Tom's not actually going to the premiere
there's gonna be a separate little red
carpet here first and last live
interview awesome I know that this is an
action-packed movie and so I'm wondering
which of the three of you had the
toughest stunts while filming while work
is a lot less comfortable than he makes
it really because it's a pretty rare so
yeah expect a lot of fun from from the
th spider-boy here I remember in the
first spider-man if we ever film stuff
where I was upside down we would just
stick my hair up and film it right way
up if you go upside down it your veins
pop out in your head pretty rooster
brothers didn't know that trick so in
this film there's a shot on my face like
about to explode like who is the best on
behind the scenes you know who you've
been hanging out the most wings
I got very well with Chris Pratt on this
one Chris Pratt and I became very close
he's really funny he's such a sweet guy
he's so talented the way he navigates
around a set and the way he treats
everyone is real role model for me and
we've become very close he was in London
the other day I took him out for a drink
and it was lovely to catch up and he's
hey everybody it's Charlie so if you
guys didn't see they just had the
Avengers infinity war London premiere
screening where they screen like that 20
minutes of the film they did a bunch of
interviews so naturally there's a lot of
funny moments a lot of the actors
talking about their roles in the film so
this is sort of like a balance of the
really cool stuff and just like really
funny haha stuff like Tom Holland
sitting there trying not to give away
spoilers this is gonna be my last live
interview ever this is just the first
one of these that they've done they're
gonna be going all over the world so
they're gonna be talking about all kinds
of cool stuff so I'll do videos for
stuff like this along with just
straight-up comic book and movie
explainers like Santos's backstory if
you are finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos it's only gonna get crazier as we
get closer to the premiere and there's
that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway that
I'll talk about at the end of the video
the really important stuff that they
talked about during this like I'll talk
about the funny moments too but the
important stuff is Doctor Strange
talking about why it was important that
he read the whole script it has
absolutely nothing to do with how
powerful the actors are like Robert
Downey jr. is probably the most powerful
Marvel actor right now he earns the most
money Benedict Cumberbatch very big deal
internationally but the reason why they
let him read the whole script is is
because he says he has a central role in
the movie much bigger than I would have
thought before Doctor Strange is an
important character he wields the time
stone he's the sorcerer supreme but the
key thing he says during this is that
he's trying to hold the multiverse
together in the comics when Thanos tries
to assemble the Infinity Gauntlet to
change the universe he's only dealing
with the six one six main Marvel
Universe of the comics it's not like a
big multiverse thing like during Secret
Wars Doctor Strange had a secret
Infinity Gauntlet that he saved from an
alternate universe that they were able
to use at the end of that story
they get to this more complicated rules
about like how you can borrow stuff from
other universes but we've only just
introduced the concept of the multi
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe like we
have Dormammu in the Dark Dimension we
have a bunch of other universes the
Doctor Strange travelled through so it
sounds like part of the movie is them
dealing with the consequences of what
Thanos is trying to do like it will
affect the multiverse so that's why
Benedict Cumberbatch playing Doctor
Strange needs to understand the logic of
what Thanos is doing whereas the other
actors like spider-man like he jokes
about trying to get the script and he
just I gave up after a couple minutes I
wasn't gonna happen and while they were
on set filming those scenes or while
they were on the Titan set filming those
big battle scenes where they were
fighting Thanos Tom Hollands said that
he didn't know who he was fighting
because the other person was basically
just the CG construct so they had
somebody else standing in for Thanos a
lot of the other actors had the same
treatment like you're battling one of
the black order here but they wouldn't
tell them who they were fighting just
person with spear in a mocap suit so
that wasn't enough when they were doing
that they also didn't give Tom Hollands
script pages they just said you're
fighting this person get into this big
battle here and they would feed him
Alliance as he needed him like when he's
on the bus here with Ned Leeds like a
create a distraction they didn't even
give him script pages for that because
they're really only a number of actors
that have a ton of dialogue like Spider
Man has lines but most of it is him just
being spider-man in these big fights
with quippy dialogue in that you don't
need a lot of script pages for just
imagine the Russos during this big titan
battle while they were filming feeding
him a bunch of different quips while
he's swinging around
he also jokes about some of the
spider-man stunts in the different ways
the different Marvel movies treat that
so that's why you always hear about
people like James Gunn or the people
from the other movies like the Ant Man
of the wasp director consulting on the
big Avengers team ups so that when
different directors like the Russos are
using characters that were already
established in other movies they keep
the character within continuity like it
was reported that James Gunn wrote all
the dialogue for the guardians of the
galaxy scenes and there's actually a lot
of the guardians of the galaxy in the
movie they talked about the 20 minutes
of footage that they screen for people
at this London premiere I've already
talked a little bit about those scenes
is really two big scenes it's the
sanctum battle and then Thor meeting the
guardians of the galaxy so it's all
stuff from trailers that most people
have already seen the movie is about 2
hours and 36 minutes long
so think about all the movie that people
have not seen I also attached that
Spider Man clip with him talking about
spending most of his time with the
guardians of the galaxy and star-lords
character so for the most part what
you've seen in the trailers makes it
seem like he spends most of his time on
team Iron Man they go to Titan they have
this big battle so it just sounds like
that's where most of Spider Man scenes
during the movie happen and then you
have like all this separate stuff
happening in Wakanda the people that
were in the Wakanda scenes like Team
Black Panther said that the funniest
person behind scenes was Mark Ruffalo
and that makes it sound like he really
is going to be banner for most of the
film but what will happen is is in the
next week they're gonna be doing more
and more of this kind of stuff so I'll
try to cherry pick like the funniest or
most interesting stuff and do videos
with that so I'll balance that out with
the videos that I do for just like
straight-up plot and characters leave
all your requests in the comments below
I've gotten a lot of requests to do a
video for Thanos his backstory because
they cut it from the film so I'll try to
explain how they've changed that for the
movie universe because this comic book
backstory is very different but there
was a whole bunch of big announcements
in the comic book TV universe today so
I'll try to add that in the relevant
videos like I have a Titans video coming
up the legends of tomorrow finale is
airing tonight so I'll do a video for
that later tonight so just be sure to
check everything out you can follow me
on Twitter for updates too I'll post the
link to my Twitter account in that top
pin comment so just be sure to check out
the comments and I'll name a giveaway
winner when I post new Marvel so click
here for that brand new infinity war
trailer video and click here for that
brand new Han Solo trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight